[Musique]
il ya toujours au guichet de pénible
recherche de monnaie et d'âpres
discussions au portillon et les visages
sont aussi toujours un peu semblable les
visages du métro celui de l'ouvrier
encore un peu endormi au matin ce
désamour et les plus immuable que tel et
les attitudes sans gêne de monsieur qui
veut à tout prix tenir son journal il ya
toujours de temps en temps quelques dix
ans en relogeant son voyage bien au delà
des tunnels et qui se réveille juste à
temps pour oublier quelque chose
aussi depuis cinquante ans un endroit à
changer un endroit s'est agrandi le
bureau des objets trouvés justement
ah et puis il ya aussi quelque chose de
disparus la veille courtoisie de la
belle époque il a fait place à une forme
plus particulière de la bio zéro
[Musique]